six months after germany saw its first
coroner case
many germans feel relatively at ease
but germany's leading research institute
warns that the worst
may be yet to come
ladies and gentlemen this latest rise in
covet 19 cases here in germany is
leaving all of us here
at the robert koch institute very
concerned
after we had managed to keep the number
of cases stable for several weeks
we have again seen a significant rise in
cases
for several days the government warns
that the new kobe 19 clusters must be
contained to prevent a second wave
if now in the summer through our leisure
and travel behavior
we cause a rise in the rate of
infections or in
overall infections then it will become
all the harder to keep the situation
under control this autumn
so far germany's health system has not
been overstretched by the virus
over the last six months more than 200
000 people in germany
were confirmed to have coronavirus and
more than 9000
lost their lives polls show
germans continue to support the cautious
approach of angela merkel's government
i believe that the government has
controlled the crisis as well
compared to other countries germany has
managed
in face of new outbreaks germany has
announced
it will introduce mandatory tests for
travelers returning from high risk
countries
we're joined now by ralph brinkhouse
he's parliamentary leader of chancellor
angela merkel's cdu csu group
in the german bundestag mr brinkhouse
welcome
germany is introducing mandatory tests
for people returning from high-risk
countries
but tests for all aren't legally
possible
do you think it's time for parliament to
consider creating new options
no it's no time for everyone to pay
attention to the virus it's no time for
everyone
to take responsibility and if i'm in a
situation that i have to travel or that
i have traveled into high-risk countries
i guess it's a personal obligation for
for everybody
to get tested out of his responsibility
for the others so we are talking a lot
about of political measures like this
mandatory tests now for people coming
back from those countries
but i guess we have to talk more about
the single individual responsibility of
everybody
and if people don't take that individual
responsibility would you
be in favor of mandating tests for
everyone
so we have to watch the situation very
carefully because
as you have mentioned in the report
we are in a situation that we have
higher figures of
people who get infected and out of this
reason we have to be more careful than
we used to be in the last
weeks this is quite normal this is not a
second wave but this is a situation
that we have higher figures and out of
this reason we have to be more careful
we have now the situation that many
people
are coming back from abroad not only
from european countries but also from
other countries
and so this is a new risk this risk is
higher than
let's say in in in march or april
because of the summer holidays
and so we have to pay attention you
talked about the higher figures and uh
germany's robert koch institute
itself is very concerned about these
higher figures that you alluded to
but you yourself looking at busy scenes
in parks and airports here in germany
do you believe that a second wave can be
prevented
yeah a second wave can be prevented if
each individual takes
responsibility so keeping a distance
not being in big crowds and have all
these protections
you need and i guess there are many many
possibilities for everybody
to take care about the others and people
not all because most of the germans are
very
responsive in this case but
many of them have forgotten about it and
so
it's the tasks not only about of media
but
also from the political side
to to switch the attention of the people
to this item to say okay
you have to be carefully well this was
about germany but what about the
inner eu borders how close do you think
we are to seeing potentially
new checks and tests at these inner eu
borders
so if every country within the european
union is taking responsibility i guess
we can avoid it
so if you have local hotspots of corona
i guess
we have to fight against this local hot
spots
and not to close borders and so every
country within the european union
is in the responsibility that we can
keep our borders open because this is
one of the main items of the european
union
to keep the borders open individual
responsibility and keeping the borders
open the message from ralph brinkhouse
leader of the conservative cdu csu group
in parliament thank you so much
thank you let's have a quick look now at
some other developments in the
coronavirus pandemic global debts from
the virus
have topped 650 000 with nearly a third
of those
thought to have been in europe alone
that's as far as if a renewed surge in
infections push a number of countries
to reimpose restrictions not long after
they were lifted
china has reported its first case of
domestic transmission in more than two
weeks
with a number of new clusters of the
infections scattered around the country
and in vietnam authorities have put the
country's fifth biggest city
danang on lockdown after 15 coronavirus
infections
were discovered in hospital public
transport has been cancelled
in and out of the city which is home to
more than one million people